like i i feel i feel if darling if i
watch darling in the franxx without
having been in the anime community i
would hate it but i
love the experience that it gave me yeah
just like being a part of the dumpster
fire and like threatening the voice
actors
oh my god that [ __ ] was ridiculous why
why is it the first thing that happens
whenever
someone's like because the same thing
happened with domestic girlfriends yeah
yeah yeah yeah where the
the author just got death threats and
like people were just [ __ ] talking them
online like
why did why'd you do this because it's
it's because i guess they're just like
the face
of the show right or the face of the
problem that resides in the show
yeah just like they don't they don't
blame the directors or the producers
because no one can see those people
right it's always the front-facing
people
is it the japanese audience that's doing
that because i sure didn't see any of
that like
online it was i think it was i think it
was kind of universal like
in the case with domestic girlfriend a
lot of it was
like the it was definitely the asian
population i don't know if it was
specifically the japanese i know i saw a
lot of like chinese korean
uh i think because the author had to
actually come out and say it was like
foreigners so it wasn't people from
japan i don't know where it was from
yeah
it might have been from the west yeah
from other asian countries i know that
at least in the west our meme culture is
pretty [ __ ] cryptic if you're not
from
it's it's shrouded in a very large veil
of stars something that could look
extremely aggressive to someone who
doesn't understand that's
probably like a conflict well wasn't
there that like japanese illustrator who
kept like apologizing for all the
sarcastic tweets that were be made
someone like commented i think i saw
this it was like someone would reply to
their post with like
the emoji with the gun like huffing like
keep posting yeah
like because it's so good right we
understood it but obviously the japanese
created and the reply back being like
i'm sorry that you're like
i'm sorry don't please don't point that
at me like they they took that at face
value right yeah
they took down their post because they
were like they thought they were
offending you yeah yeah yeah yeah bro
[ __ ] memes are [ __ ] up yeah i
remember
the when vinland saga was airing people
were people were sending like tweets to
the uh author of vinland saga
calling him like a goat the goat the
girl right
yeah and and the author was like why are
people calling me a ghost
am i doing bad have i done something bad
yeah yeah that's the names do not
translate no they do not translate well
how are like japanese memes i've always
been curious how the japanese meme
culture is
i mean you know a lot of the japanese
memes that make it
well i mean a lot of the best memes in
my opinion stay on 2chan
which uh i i think if you know anything
about 2chan yeah
they're pretty bad yeah i know they're
like even most unfortunate oh yeah i
mean
if 4chan if you thought 4chan was bad
never going to 2chan like yeah
i remember one of my friends he uh like
he used to
be on 4chan a lot and then when i told
him about two chinese like man for the
first time in my life i'm glad i never
took japanese because if i could
understand what these threads were
saying
holy [ __ ] i would just be like oh my god
i didn't know humans could say such
horrible things to one another
it's really [ __ ] brutal over there
but the memes are
very funny the memes are great and
luckily i think a lot of the best
like probably the safest memes that
start on 2chan
do eventually make it on twitter yeah
and man those [ __ ] blow up on
japanese twitter like so crazily like
like if you thought memes on like
western twitter
we're like whoa 50 000 retweets holy
[ __ ] dude i've seen japanese memes that
have like a million retweets
i'm just like [ __ ] i mean yeah it's a
good meme but goddamn guys
i mean western twitter is just tick
tocks re-uploaded right now oh yeah
basically yeah
because i feel from what i can see with
japanese
like social media in general we've
talked about internet hate a lot on this
uh
podcast before and it feels like with
with japan it's either you're really
nice and polite or it's like the [ __ ]
worst then there's like
there's a reason why i never wanted to
start like a japanese youtube channel
because i thought about it when i first
moved here i was like
should i start a separate channel where
i've it's aimed towards the japanese
right it doesn't necessarily have to be
anime related uh i was just gonna do
like just a regular like vlog style
channel but all in japanese
and then i watched a bunch of japanese
youtubers because before i never really
watched japanese youtubers and i saw
their comments sections and i'm just
like
nah i don't i don't want that i don't
want any of that [ __ ]
because like man some of the [ __ ]
like hate
like some of the [ __ ] hate movements
that happen towards
japanese youtubers are crazy i remember
there was one
uh japanese youtuber who and on japanese
youtubers
you [ __ ] up once your career is done
because they will hold on to that [ __ ]
for the rest of your career until you're
gone because there was one japanese
youtuber
a little bit yeah but like to a
completely different i don't know about
that i mean people people have very
short memories yeah how many times is
like the paul brothers [ __ ] up and
they're still getting like decent views
right but there was this one japanese
youtuber who
didn't even do anything bad he he had a
pet goldfish
and the goldfish died and so he threw
the goldfish
like he drained it down the toilet okay
basically right
really standard right of course that's
what you normally do it got so much hate
that even on at this day and this
happened like
four or five years ago i don't know
about the accuracy of this don't quote
me on this but it happened like four or
five years ago
and since then every single one of his
videos have gotten a 50 percent dislike
ratio
damn just from that one thing that he
did and people are still holding on to
him for it
i just think they they have like they
they
keep on to hate for like another for
like another level yeah
and i think i think that's why the idol
culture here must be so
scary because you [ __ ] up once here if
you're an idol or a voice actress or
something and
your career is just done it's just they
just expect perfection from you
yeah it definitely feels like they uh
the image that you build
they immediately like are in control of
it and yeah
that if yeah like you said if you [ __ ]
up once it's like they're almost like
entitled to you
yeah yeah perfect yeah pretty much if
you ruin it well you ruined this thing i
liked
you did that yeah you ruined this thing
i enjoyed you know it's like what do you
mean it's just me
yeah right it's like it's like it's
sometimes they forget that some of these
people are just humans right yeah
and it's kind of this mentality where
they're not allowed to be human in a lot
of ways and
that's what it feels like because i
remember the first story i've
i ever heard like about this kind of
situation happening in the anime
community was probably with
um ayah hirano yeah like harry he's
voice actress like there was a scandal
like back in the day scandal quote
unquote scandal but back in the day when
she was voicing in haruhi she was
voicing lucky star
she was like the triple a-list celebrity
right she was like one of the hottest
names in this industry
and i think what happened is that she
had a she had a music career as well she
had a band
and i think she slept with everyone in
the band
except for the bass guitar player
which everybody every bassist
like like a moment of silence for the
bass guitar player there
give you 504 subscribers why is it
always the basis
but yeah that that story like got outed
and
her career just like went from like a
plus triple a to like she had a trouble
yeah she she completely disappeared
after that
yeah since then she's disappeared and
she's trying to she's since then she's
only had like a few bigger roles
i think the only last world i remember
her doing was uh
doing miggy from what's that parasite
parasite yeah
kind of happened in the west though a
little bit yeah
oh yeah well like an entire career
against you're not going to try korean
being destroyed at least [ __ ] twitter
would be like
[ __ ] clowning oh yeah but this
happened way before the twitter thing
came out
right like this happened in like the mid
two thousand like the lights online are
like
pretty [ __ ] like would you mean
you've slept yeah this seems to be scary